Terrible scandal,
Ève Gilles should not have been elected Miss
France At the ceremony last Saturday,
Miss Nord Pas de Calais was crowned Miss France deux-mille-vingt
-quatre by 1 jury exclusively female.
However,
this victory has triggered 1 national controversy,
taking many observers by surprise .
..
Social networks have launched 1 avalanche of criticism of evgyl,
sometimes describing her in a mocking way and
comparing her to cartoon characters .
..
The main criticisms focused on her lack of shape,
her thinness and especially her short hair.
Disturbing revelations emerged from an official document
stating that the public had not placed Miss North.
No Calais at the top of its preferences and even far from there.
Contrary to the opinion of the jury,
the favorites of the public were Miss Guyana,
followed by Miss Guadeloupe and Miss Provence.
This discrepancy raises questions about the balance between
the public vote and the jury vote,
which is normally supposed to count at 50.50 in the selection process.
The jury's decision bypassing the public's choices explains why 1 majority of French
people express their disagreement with the Miss France election.